I'm Audrey Justin and this is Bill your
squad I'm here with bleacher report to
pick my all-time squad
okay so first so you have all
quarterbacks here I like I like all of
them but I'm gonna go with Dan Marino
he's my favorite quarterback all the
time running backs I'll go with Barry
Sanders the reason I choose him because
of what he did with the offensive line
that he had you see was Randy Moss Randy
was a super explosive man you can do it
all be beans
this is tough for Deion Sanders you
could put him on an IV cover anything
and lie back I'm going we're at Lawrence
Taylor the most dominating player
dominating players of all time man I'm
just a fan of football
I'm fed up all of it but uh Jerry Rice
definitely he's gay rights probably the
greatest player of all the time I
probably say the biggest one that's why
Ward number 80 Dan Marino he's just my
favorite quarterback of all time I mean
I think he threw a hell of a football
Barry Sanders what he did with the team
that he had was I mean I think he's the
best running back of all the time in my
opinion Randy Moss he could do it all
you know he could catch the short route
take it the distance or he'd get run by
it run through coverage run by everybody
Deion Sanders I mean he could just lock
down one side of the field and Lawrence
tale he's I think he's the most dominant
player of all
I'm Andre Johnson and that was build the
squad